here you emailed us and you mentioned
that you've been very very fortunate
with Sherman song and then it has had
such an amazing reception that you
really weren't expecting that what did
you envision did you think that you were
going to put something out and it was
just going to be a great job and a pat
on the back or I mean yeah you know it
is a filmmaker and myself I never make a
film expecting to get you know huge
accolades especially the ones we've
gotten from for Sherman song like we won
rain dance the phone with a festival and
audience award a Phoenix Film Festival
and you know I've never won awards
before like that and I've never been to
the international festivals and you know
the type of audience is coming up to me
afterwards and saying how much as touch
them and I was in the Bahamas and a
screening a bohemian come up to me said
I think this is gonna be a classic one
day like I thought the meat classic and
that kind of stuff like you don't you
can't expect that to happen like when
you're making a film all you're thinking
about its just God I need to finish this
film and hopefully one festival is gonna
take it you know so it's something I
never ever thought would happen
so so you're not envisioning what
festivals you're going to enter while
you're editing the film no I mean
there's this of course the Sundance
dream you know everyone has that one and
the top 10 tier festivals of course the
ideal is to turn a world premiere at
that one and then ideally maybe a
distributor will not pay upfront police
on you it with a deal you know like you
know there's those those those
aspirations of kind of the brass ring
reaching that kind of thing and if you
don't hit it all those you know it's
cool all those like consultants or other
filmmakers or all those people that tell
you like if you don't make it there your
films not dead like there's actually a
path and you have a viable career doing
different different way there's not just
the Sundance way or whatever you know so
you know I went to these other festivals
where which were just as amazing in
terms of audience response and meeting
people in networking meeting other
producers and screen writers and actors
and getting a distribution deal already
and being able to just you know like do
all those things that without making it
at Sundance I've got those deals I'm
doing for that theatrical on my own but
i'm actually making money doing it vs
hey if i sold it and you know there's
marketing in PA and all these other
costs that the distributor might keep
before you see anything so it's you know
you can do it on your own in a different
way and you still make money at it and
it's not what you expect that path but
it's this path and it's still just as
viable
you